-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
The United Auto Workers
yesterday
endorsed President Biden.
Really?
President Amtrak?
You might as well have endorsed
Usain Bolt.
[ Laughter ]
In a post
on Truth Social,
former President Trump
said that anyone
who donates
to Nikki Haley's campaign
will be permanently barred
from the MAGA camp,
quote, "from this moment forth."
What?
[ Laughter ]
From this moment forth?
What's going on?
You know, Trump is stressed
when he starts talking
like a dungeon master.
[As Trump]
From this moment forth,
all my enemies
shall bow before me.
No, you roll those dice
to see if you have to bow.
[ Laughter ]
Presidential candidate
Nikki Haley premiered
a new campaign ad yesterday
in South Carolina
that calls her, quote,
"America's new chapter."
As opposed to Trump,
who's aiming to be
more of an epilogue.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report
from a watchdog group,
former President Trump's
White House pharmacy
prepared go bags
of prescription medications
for overseas trips,
including Ambien,
or as Trump calls it,
"my speechwriter."
[ Laughter ]
Hillary Clinton released
a statement yesterday
in support of Barbie director
Greta Gerwig
and actress Margot Robbie,
after they did not receive
Oscar nominations,
and wrote, quote, "You are both
so much more than Kenough."
Oh, my God, Mom,
don't talk to my friends!
[ Laughter ]
Don't you have
somewhere to Pokémon Go?
[ Laughter ]
Mom!
I told you when you drove us
to the movie --
Don't quote it!
[ Laughter ]
The House Ethics Committee has
reportedly contacted the woman
who Florida Congressman
Matt Gaetz
has been accused of sleeping
with when she was a minor.
If convicted, Gaetz could
serve up to four years
as vice president.
[ Laughter and groans ]
Ring a little too true?
Officials at a British zoo
have reintegrated
a pair of profanity-spewing
parrots with their flock
in hopes it will help
clean up their language.
And I don't know
what they've been saying,
but if British people
are offended, you know it's bad.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new ranking
by The Wall Street Journal,
Alaska Airlines was the second
best domestic carrier of 2023.
They really blew the doors
off the competition.
I know, it's...
Yeah.
I'm guessing voting for that
was a couple months ago.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, today
was National Florida Day.
To learn more
about Florida's history,
go to school somewhere else.
And, you guys...
that was a monologue.